hey little guys my name is trying to
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we draft OS triangle
definitely check out that video if you
haven't already and today we're gonna
talk about shaders do you guys don't
know what shaders are I would recommend
that you check out my opengl series it's
the series all about OpenGL and I
specifically focus on the graphics part
of it and it is a series that is still
actually going on I haven't stopped it
I've just kind of thrown pause to focus
on the game and in series but as the
game in this series kind of gets more
into graphics as it is right now
I'm gonna start off that series again
I'm gonna start off s tears again and
actually deal with more of the kind of
in-depth explanations and stuff like
that to do with graphics specifically
because I realized that not everyone is
like obsessed with graphics and this is
a game engine serious so definitely
check out the video on shaders in the
opengl series in fact check out that
whole series because that's really going
to teach you all the core kind of stuff
about graphics specifically we are still
gonna discuss what shaders are there
because everyone needs to know what
shaders are doesn't matter if you're
dealing with graphics or not if you're a
game engine developer you need to
understand what shaders are because
they're incredibly important without
shaders you really wouldn't see anything
on the screen
at all so I mean even if you're just a
game engine developer trying to debug
events and then I don't know something
goes wrong with something that's on the
screen or something is not working
correctly or you get an error or a
shared a compilation failure or
something you should be able to fix that
so we are definitely gonna talk about
what shaders are and we're actually
going to write out those shaders for the
hazel engine right now today but first I
want to give a huge thank you to all the
patrons that made this series possible
patron icon for size for sure know is
that link if you go over there you can
help support this series you'll get
really cool rewards such as access to
private channels where I can discuss
what I'm gonna do next
and you'll also get access to behavioral
development repository which contains
all the code that I've actually written
for hazel but haven't actually put into
videos yet so what I typically tend to
do is I actually work on hazel kind of
spare time I kind of just develop it as
an as I would an engine and then I take
kind of code from that and that's what I
actually end up teaching so it's like a
sandbox for me to play around with but
also kind of plan the engine design and
architecture and all that and it's got
some pretty cool stuff in it I'm not
gonna lie like I mean yeah it's a lot
more advanced than what you see here in
fact you know what I've been saying that
for like episodes and episodes you guys
aren't seeing anything why don't I show
you what is in that hazel development
repository let's just jump in and take a
look all right so check this out this is
currently the hazel engine as it appears
in the hazel development repository
which patrons get access to so this
right now is some kind of PBR demo that
I've just put together it's by no means
perfect I'm still working on it it's a
little pretty good though here we have a
bunch of balls with just varying
roughnesses and the bottoms are metals
the top are dielectrics which are
basically plastics or any kind of a
nonmetal material you can see we've got
a cube map which we can do in kind of
rotate and you can see that that
environment map is showing up on the
kind of less rough surfaces here as they
would currently the I mean I've done a
few things I'm not gonna discuss this
too much but currently you can see that
the reflection isn't a hundred percent
smooth that's just because I'm relying
on like a bit of a trick which is just
kind of generating the cube map mitts on
the fly just using OpenGL and sort of
actually pre filtering them properly if
I turn that on for a second you'll see
that it looks a lot nicer but it runs at
like one frame per second because that's
supposed to be done offline and then
like not done actually per pixel anyway
and in fact if we take a look at the
Model View we can even load a model this
model is just is by um I'll leave the
link to this kind of in the description
below if you guys are interested to
check it out but if we you can actually
load any mesh you want here as well as
any texture you want so if I kind of
navigate to the actual textures from
this I can load the albedo texture here
you can see that's what it looks like I
can use that I can load the normals
texture I can load a metalness texture
and I can load a roughness texture if I
just use all of those you can see that
what I have here is quite a nice-looking
gun which has like all the reflections
as you can see over the kind of cube map
over here and yeah
basically you can see that like I mean
the hazel development repository is
pretty cool this what you see right here
on the screen is exactly where this
series is headed so for those of you who
are like oh you know we drew our first
triangle after like eight months how
long is it going to take we're gonna
have this on the screen by the year by
the end of the year for sure but it's
just important to note that a lot of the
stuff that I did in the first eight
months was to make stuff like this
really easy all the stuff that we
covered like a vent systems layers
setting up like dll and static libraries
properly all of that stuff the maths
library that stuff is important so that
you can just like do this effectively
this took me I think about two or three
days to get this whole thing up and
running because everything was just
ready I'm GUI was ready all the maths
libraries were ready just everything was
just setup events were ready everything
was set up and ready to kind of go which
made this kind of thing really really
simple let me see if I can get like some
nice lighting here so yeah you can see
that I mean it looks pretty cool if you
want access to this card straight like
right now you can just help support the
stories on patron accomplice Ashley
Turner and you can just literally just
grab this look at all the cards look at
all the shaders play around with it do
whatever you want just like that and in
fact if we just go back to the spheres
for a second
the spheres in fact will show these
textures as well and you can see that
that doesn't look pretty cool if I just
get rid of the normals and maybe the
metalness
I'll keep the metalness you can see how
nice and like rough certain surfaces
look here I mean although it is this
particular roughness map anyway oh and
it's even like full HDR as well so
there's exposure you can kind of like
overexposed here and then dial it down
you can see it's all kind of HDR which
is pretty cool so there we go and
finally maples let's just change the
light radians get rid this stuff and you
can kind of see how that works as well
with all the lighting it's way too
bright there and let's maybe get
somewhere here cool all right so that is
the awesome hazel develop and rush
that's a preview for all of you guys
watching this series as to where we're
heading with this whole graphics
component um it's gonna be pretty cool
so I'm really looking forward to doing
all this stuff in the future all right
cool
so anyway back to shaders because
without shade is where understanding how
shadows work we can't do anything that
you saw us on the screen because shaders
are extremely important because what
they actually do is they're programs
that run on the graphics card but you
tell the graphics card what to do with
the job that we actually send it so it's
really important to understand the
graphics pipeline as a whole I actually
really want to make a video about the
graphics pipeline and about how graphics
are right there probably as part of the
OpenGL series so keep an eye out for
that this would be a good time to
subscribe if you haven't already we're
gonna cover kind of how that works but
specifically what happens usually in a
in a typical rendering scenario is we
send a bunch of data to the GPU in the
form of like a vertex buffer and index
buffer you know send shader parameters
shader uniforms that kind of thing
and then what we need to do is actually
kind of get that data on the GPU and
then process it and the way that that's
done primarily is through shaders and
specifically to different types of
shaders so there are a lot of different
types of shaders but there are two types
of shaders which are used more than like
any other shaders and that is the vertex
shader and the fragment shader which is
also which is also known as the pixel
shader in our the rendering api's OpenGL
calls that the fragment shader there are
reasons for that but making DirectX and
then like you know most other kind of
API is like the you know console API
stuff like that it's known as a pixel
shader which basically if we kind of
break that down what that means is that
a veteran that runs on the GPU for every
vertex that we decide to render so a
vertex is just a position in 3d space
when we rendered the triangle last
episode we defined three vertices right
we have the top of the triangle left
kind of side the right side and what
happened
we sent those three vertices to the GPU
we executed something called a draw call
in which we said draw these three
vertices right and then what OpenGL
actually did was it processed those
three vertices in the vertex shader the
vertex shader runs once per vertex so
effectively the vertex shader runs three
times right and the vertex shader is
responsible for actually figuring out
the position of those vertices in clip
space so we kind of were already we
didn't have a share the last time right
so we were kind of already in clip space
which meant that our coordinate system
with it was between negative 1 and 1 on
all axes and last episode we kind of
discussed that so usually the message
header is responsible for actually
translating any kind of thing that we
have any kind of vertex data that we
have into that kind of negative one to
one space that's effectively the output
of the vertex shader we need to tell
OpenGL hey this is my vertex data I'm
going to process it usually by
multiplying it with like a Model View
projection matrix to get it into that
negative one to one space and of course
we'll cover that in the future and the
opengl series I believe has already
covered that so definitely check that
out and then we move on the pipeline
eventually getting to the fragment
shader and the fragment shader runs per
pixel okay so the veteran shader per
vertex which means it runs three times
now the fragment shader needs to feel in
that triangle it needs to shade that
triangle that's the point of the other
of the pixel shader right it's called a
pixel shader or fragment shader because
it runs per pixel or per fragment right
so what it does and what the output of
that is is it figures out what color
that pixel actually needs to be so runs
for every pixel that open GL needs to
shade it so obviously depending on how
big your triangle is on your computer
screen that means that's how many times
it will run right so if it's really
small triangle probably run like just a
handful of times if it's huge it might
run like a million times right and you
need to shade that triangle in a
particular color so what we're going to
do today is we're gonna make a red
triangle so we're gonna tell OpenGL
that hey I want you to put these vertex
positions
to this particular place and I want you
to shade every pixel red or something
like that right now what you saw here in
the kind of hazel developing branch
obviously that was doing a lot more than
just shading it a solid color it was
doing a whole bunch of lighting
calculations a whole bunch of like
sampling something called a cube map
which is basically the environment that
we're into kind of because that actually
influences the lighting via something
called image based lighting it does a
whole bunch of operations and texture
lookups and everything to actually try
and figure that out and it does that per
pixel most of that lighting stuff is
done in the actual pixel shader in fact
there's very little stuff is actually
done in the vertex shader most of the
vertex what most of what the vertex
shader does is actually send stuff to
that fragment shader and interpolates it
and does a bunch of other stuff right
and that's what we'll kind of talk about
here as well because another thing we
can do is we can actually pass data from
the vertex shader to the fragment shader
anyway there's all kind of very hard to
understand without diagrams of actually
looking at the graphics pipeline so I
don't want to spend too much on that all
you need to know is that we need to tell
the GPU what to do with data we send it
vertex shader tells it what to do with
the vertex data that it receives
specifically its primary responsibility
is to point out where in that window in
our clip space do the vertices actually
lie in right so it does that
transformation and the pixel shader or
the fragment shader takes in that data
right from you usually you would give it
data from the actual vertex shader right
and it figures out what color everything
needs to be when we dive into more
advanced kind of shaders in the OpenGL
series I'm not gonna do it in the game
administer is probably but when we dive
into more advanced things in the OpenGL
series which actually might move on
through next week or the week after
we're actually going to talk about
various lighting algorithms and how all
the dotter kind of comes together that's
gonna be a lot of fun because I love
graphics and I know that a lot of you
guys do as well but the primary
responsibilities there is just
determining what color the pixel that
it's processing currently needs to be
all right anyway let's just dive in take
a look at how shaders work write our own
shaders and see
we can get that triangle read okay so if
you check out this link here which I
will link in the description below
basically open the opengl wiki which is
on kind of Chronos org it has this
article about Shetty compilation because
what we need to do is actually compile
these shaders they're just regular
programs they're specified in this
OpenGL shading language instead of C++
but effectively is just like a bunch of
code and what do we need to do with code
we need to compile it and turn it into
some kind of program so that's what this
article kind of just takes you through
right so it's really important that you
read this you can also check out my
opengl series video on shaders I think
that covers quite a lot of this as well
but I would recommend that you read
through this whole thing because again
you need to understand how it works
because when things go wrong it's going
to be a little bit hard to actually find
out what the problem is if you have no
idea what you're doing alright anyway
there's a full compiled link example of
a vertex and fragment shader over here
we're literally going to just copy this
there is absolutely no point in writing
us out by yourself I really really hope
that you will read through this card and
in fact I'm going to explain it in this
video because I can't just paste a bunch
of code and not explain it I think
that's really stupid but that card will
compile a vertex and fragment shader you
don't really need to modify it much it
will pretty much remain as is in our
engine apart maybe aside from like minor
modifications okay so this is clearly
OpenGL specific code so technically
speaking this should belong in platform
OpenGL but I actually want to make a
video I think in the future about how
we're actually good like what our
platform but what our rendering API
abstraction strategy is actually going
to be because that's gonna be kind of
the template we use for pretty much
every render API specific class not
render a class but render API specific
class so for now we'll just stick it
into hazal renderer but that's gonna
definitely move and in fact we'll just
call it shader but again that's going to
move into an OpenGL specific file which
will be called something like OpenGL
shader right okay so we'll stick this
into the hazal namespace and I'll just
call this class shade up okay we're
going to have a construct
which for now we're just going to take
the shader program in via just strings
essentially so we'll have our vertex
source and our fragment source so these
are going to be the source codes for our
shadows in the future we're going to
take this in as a file but for now it's
going to live like this we're also just
gonna have a normal kind of destructor
here not like a virtual one or anything
in the future like we'll talk about this
in the renderer API videos but in the
future we kind of want to have
subclasses of this essentially that will
be implemented per API
oh man in that case we would need to
make the destructor virtual so we have
bind and unbind unbind isn't really
necessary I only you really use it for
debugging purposes because usually you
don't waste time on binding things you
just bind the next thing you need but
yeah we'll just keep it in here for kind
of debug stuff and I'll also include
string because we need that in terms of
what we need here I think really the
only thing that we want to maybe keep is
the actual like ID of the shader so
opengl gives us unsigned ends usually
sometimes just normal incest ID and i
like to call them renderer ID I think I
may have done this before maybe not so
what this is going to be is essentially
just a number that uniquely identifies
this object kind of inside OpenGL so
that we can refer to it okay so we'll
make a shader CPP file we'll just put it
obviously next to the header file called
shader CBP will include our PCH will
include our shader header file we'll put
this into the hazal namespace and we'll
implement all of these if I right click
here I can create the method
implementations using the visual assist
and finally what we're going to do now
is is go back to that website copy that
code because I have done a lot of
copying since then and just paste it
into the constructor it's gonna be nice
and simple so here we go
paste it into the constructor and of
course we'll modify some of this stuff
now first thing I'll do is include glad
because we need access to OpenGL vertex
sauce fragments were already taking
I might just get rid of that entirely
and slightly rename this to just SRC and
fragment sauce I might as well rename
defragment sauce okay cool and other
than that you can say we get in our
compiler errors or anything
according to intellisense so let's take
a look at this code line by line so the
first thing we do is we actually create
shader you'll note that a lot of the
stuff that we've been doing in OpenGL
right now if we go to application I
think is like gen riot so GL gen buffers
shield generate x-rays there's actually
a bit of a newer API and I think opengl
4.5 or even 4.6 which is actually just
GL create instead of jail gen they've
kind of consolidated that and made it a
lot more consistent and will probably
switch to it when we actually make these
kind of classes what I think we'll
switch to it because I don't think I
have much of a desire to support
anything below kind of opengl 4.5 but
create gen will actually this kind of
gen call will only assign us with a
unique ID it won't actually create the
object in OpenGL like on our GPU it's it
actually gets created when we do the
binding for the first time with a
particular target like a ray buffer here
whereas create actually creates
everything like actually it actually
creates everything doesn't just give us
an ID it actually creates everything on
a GPU like allocates memory and does all
that stuff and actually validates the
object so create is used in this case
instead of gen now you don't know why
ultimately everything is going to be
created in the future it is now it's
just that if you look at a lot of OpenGL
card prior to like opengl 4.5 it's
always gen and buying gem in mind
instead of just create which is kind of
the new way of doing things what we're
doing here is basically just getting
this source we don't really need to cast
this to a constant your char in fact
this can just be like the C string is a
is a contra this this this is I mean if
you look at what GL char is they like to
use their own kind of primitives IRA I
don't really like this just because
usually when I'm dealing with OpenGL I'm
writing cross-platform on rather cross
rendering API kind of code I'm not just
you know implementing an engine in which
with a single API and so because of that
I like to just have everything the same
so you can see over here I used you and
32t instead of like Glu and because
first of all to get Glu and I'd have to
include the up in jail header here but
also why use it if like I know what it's
going to be and I don't want to kind of
have a different thing every time in
fact this probably will end up looking
something like a renderer ID with render
ID being defined as a UN 32k but in this
case you can see they are using the
right kind of a this code out is as is
and not do too much to it I think what
this does is just sends our source code
to OpenGL right I mean the comment even
even says that sends it to our vertex
shader which we generated this is the ID
for our pet actuator and then it just
compiles it right and now what this code
does is actually checks to see if the
compilation succeeded or if it failed so
if the compiled status here we're
checking the compiled status we're
getting that kind of integer from OpenGL
and we're saving it into here if that is
false it means that it in compiled
successfully so what our next steps are
is to figure out why didn't compiled
successfully so what we do here is we
actually get the length of the log
message which says why it didn't compile
so that just gives us a length like how
many characters it is and then what
we're doing is we're shoving all of that
information so OpenGL has a log which
says why it's like an error message
which basically just says why our shader
doesn't compile we're getting that and
we're shoving it into this vector now I
think I believe in my OpenGL series I
actually Alec aid so I used alakay to
just allocate memory on the stack and I
think it was just a gel char or like at
just a cha kind of array you can do that
in here they're doing a vector which is
dynamically allocated but they are
providing max length here anyway my
point is it's not the most efficient
solution but it doesn't really matter
probably won't notice this this only
happens when a shared compilation fails
which you know in distribution builds
really should this code should never
ever get hit anyway so I'm not gonna be
all like pedantic about how this is
written but effectively all you need to
know is that log that error message from
OpenGL we take it and we put it into
this vector of jail Charles okay and
then we delete the shader because we
don't need it anymore this pretty much
happens anyway
well we detached it we don't delete it
at the end but you know there's no need
for this to stay around because
obviously this particular shader which
we created and tried to compile didn't
compiled successfully so get rid of it
so we have this info log so what we need
to do here if this just returns it but
what we'll do is we'll just write h said
probably call error which will just be
like our error message so we might write
something like vertex shader compilation
failure and then I might do another
error which is actually going to be our
error message so I'll just write here
what should we do probably just infer
log data okay same as writing I was
going to write infer log zero like that
with a memory address there which just
kind of gives us the first char and then
obviously it's a child pointer so the
logging library will know what to do
with it but we can also just do it for
logged up data okay and then I think
I'll assert okay so H there to call
assert or maybe I'll actually move this
into the assert here so we're just
assert here and obviously we just assert
false okay cool so there we go now we
basically are logging the problem that
has occurred in our vertex at a
compilation all right guess what the
next thing is identical except we like
find/replace vertex with fragment right
so we make a fragment shader we get the
source for actually using the source
variable here I'll just clean this up we
compile it we get the log length again
if it failed we do all of this stuff
this actually delayed
both of them because that might be a
problem because we've already deleted
vertex shader in this case um I guess we
can probably return here as in we don't
need to keep compiling if if if our
shader failed to compile right in this
case delays both of them because even if
the vertex shader worked out but the
fragment shader didn't we like it's a
complete failure anyway delete
everything and then what we'll do here
is we'll just grab this stuff and pop it
here okay I'm except well obviously
right fragment shader compilation
failure okay cool so now now that
they've been successfully compiled so
that source code that we specified is
obviously like valid we take this we
create this program and the program is
just it's like a program it's literally
a program right it's going to be the
combination bus both of our shaders in
some kind of form that we can just run
on the GPU we attach the shaders to our
program because the program consists of
shaders we link the program right which
is kind of links to shaders together and
figure stuff out and now obviously the
compilation stage we know succeeded but
now we do the linking okay
and this just checks exactly the same as
what the compilation did except it
checks it for linking failures instead
of compilation failures so again we get
the link status if the link status is
false it means that that linking failed
we get the log length we get the log
data we delete everything so that we
don't leak in your resources and then
we'll just paste this in so we'll say
share the link failure okay and then
we'll get that info log again and log
that to the console and then at the end
we detach everything because we don't
need that after has been linked we don't
need the actual individual files this is
kind of similar I guess to how when we
compile in C++ if we have multiple
translation units they generate obj
files I mean even if we have one it
generates an obj file using MS PC which
is like our kind of object file from our
source code right
but then after we've linked it into an
exe file we no longer need those obj
files so this is kind of like that right
we just want to detach everything
because once I've been
into a program that's that and that's it
okay
in our destructor or we need to do is
delete the program jail delete program
and then this will be what am i doing
zero ran dry day speaking of render
ideas actually instead of taking this
into program what we actually should do
is oops is right M render ID equals gel
crea program so we want to actually
store that renderer ID in like as a
member variable so that we can then
access it obviously in different
functions and obviously we wanted to
persist outside the scope of just this
constructor now obviously you can see
you can see the program is used
everywhere here so what I might just do
is write as it was written gel you end
program equals M render ID just so that
just so that we don't need to paste M
render ID everywhere here okay cool um
there we go and obviously is not gonna
change like this this value this
variable is not gonna change throughout
here so this is like totally fine okay
cool so we delete the program and
binding it is as simple as just doing
gel use program and then render IDs this
is what we do before we want to render
something with this shader and then for
unbind we just do gel use program zero
okay cool
that's how shared a class it's super
simple now let's actually write a shader
and render our triangle with it so if I
just launched this code right now we'll
make sure that our shader class actually
compiles but also I want to see what we
have right now because we should have a
white triangle you can see that we do
wonderful let's make that thing red so
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to have
to make I'm gonna include shader over
here an application this is obviously
extremely temporary hazel renderer
shader will spill down here I'll put it
over here next to our other kind of
render IDs here so I'll write STD unique
pointer this will be a shader I'll call
this our shadow if I go back here I'm
going to write this you can do this in a
few ways you can do you know STD make
unique for
usually I like to do reset just because
it's obviously less code you can see
that's it there's no need to kind of
make unique if you're using shared
pointers you should usually kind of do
make shared just because it needs to
also allocate another another book of
memory for reference counting but with
unique pointers it doesn't really matter
so over here I'm actually going to write
a new shader and then we need some
source code so let's go ahead and
actually write some shader source code
so a lot of people really hate writing
source code in C++ like has strings
because it's just annoying but I'll show
you a little trick that makes it a lot
better so we have our vertex shader
source code which I'll write as vertex
as SRC I guess what you could do here
there's several ways of doing this right
the first way is kind of annoying and it
just means that you have to write like
you know version and like whatever
you're using 3:30 core or whatever
backslash n and then you kind of write
your whole thing out and usually the way
the way that you do that is you'd kind
of just make a new line write some code
and then you know have your backslash N
and then write a bunch of stuff and
write a bunch of stuff and if C++ sees
multiple strings together it kind of
just depends of them so this is all fine
obviously you won't get newline
characters unless you actually write
backslash n so it's kind of annoying
though because you have to write quotes
every line you have to write backslash
and every on every line you can't just
paste shader code from the internet into
here because you need to add quotes and
do all that stuff that's annoying so
instead what you should do is just use
this little prefix called R right then a
court then an open and close parenthesis
what this lets you do is actually have
multiple line strings okay
so you can see I can write stuff like
that and guess what it's all part of the
string okay so what we're gonna do is
use that and then what it's gonna write
a normal shade up so we'll write version
like 3:30 core maybe because you know
that's fine doesn't really matter what
version of shadow of the shading
language we're using here 334 should be
fine in the future we'll probably use
450 as a minimum I think this is gonna
be about a shadow so what we need to do
is take in these this
I don't remember this runs per vertex
and actually tell OpenGL where we want
this to be positioned now I'm not gonna
run through how to write shaders and
probably how everything works here but
basically what we need is a main
function here every trader has this and
we also need to take in these attributes
so the attribute being the position so
we can just write layouts location
equals zero in Veck three a underscore
position so I like to have a naming
convention which is a underscore for
attributes we're taking in avec 3
because there are three component vector
in this case doesn't matter you can take
an avec for it will actually do the
conversion for you but this layout
location zero just says that it's at
index zero you can see we enabled a
texture trouble write zero that's it
over here right this vertex with your
pointer is 0 this corresponds to this
that's actually where this attribute is
inside a vertex buffer so we taking the
position and all we're gonna do is we're
not gonna do anything to it
we're just go right position equals a
position essentially okay what this does
is tells OpenGL that the output position
of our vertex is in this case the same
as our input position which is exactly
what we have here we might play around
with this in the future just to kind of
see what it does
now jail position is a Veck fault so we
need to actually convert this to a back
fall and we'll add one on the end here
as the W component okay cool so there we
go that is our entire vertex shader done
let's copy and paste this and we'll
write our fragment shader so I'll change
this variable to be fragment source and
now instead of us kind of just inputting
a position we actually output a color so
color is a vector for I'm just gonna
call this well I don't know what to call
this I'll just call this color and this
is our Apple color you could you know do
our ones called color I don't really
have a convention to be honest for
output variables like this we'll just
call it color and color in this case
we're going to set two back for 1.0 0.0
0.0 1.0 which is
pure red might make it look a little bit
nicer by just doing 0.8 0.2 0.3 so what
this is is a full component vector here
which every component here is a color
right so we have red green blue a alpha
right so RGB a because that's the
current format of our actual frame
buffer that we're rendering 2 more on
that later okay you can set this to
anything you want but we're just gonna
set it to a nice red color okay and that
is actually it that's all you need just
this is our entire true shaders we're
gonna put them into our shader
constructor here vertex or fragment
source and then we're going to we could
bind the shade of here and leave it but
I'm just gonna bind it every frame over
here so I usually like to bind it as the
first thing I do the reason for this is
like in other rendering API is like
DirectX
you have to actually have a shader
before you even create like a vertex
buffer because the layout has to kind of
correspond OpenGL doesn't enforce that
so it doesn't matter where you bind this
as long as it's before you actually draw
this line here is that real cool but I'm
just gonna just bind it as the first
thing because in other api's you
actually have to all right cool so
that's it that's done that should work
hopefully I didn't make any mistakes but
I guess we'll see let's just run the
program and hopefully we get a red
triangle all right and as you can see
there is our beautiful red triangle now
one thing I just want to show you guys
as well is that obviously can says to
whatever call you want but with this
jail position like you can really do
anything so if I kind of just move this
by 0.5 right what this is going to do is
translate that that position by 0.5 in
every axis so instead of kind of being
actually 1.5 is a bad thing to do in
this case just because it's going to
actually end up moving it outside of our
screen because it'll move it up actually
north 25 should be fine sorry 1 will
move it up what this will do is actually
translate everything and so it'll move
all of these vertices that were kind of
inputting here by 0.5 so this will
become 1 negative 1 this one will be
sorry this one will become 0 this
zero so it'll be kind of centered it'll
basically move it right and up okay so
we should kind of see it in the top
right of our screen and we can just do
that by doing point five and as you can
see here it is right
so hopefully that kind of shows you what
that is actually responsible for it's
responsible for literally laying out our
vertices whereas this is responsible for
doing the colors now because I want to
show you something cool I will what
we're gonna do now is we're gonna
actually access this position in here
now we know first of all that this is
between negative one and one which is
already great colors need to be between
zero and one in this case right this is
between negative one and one but that's
fine let's go ahead actually write some
code that lets us access this a position
variable in here and we can see if we
can output the color like with regards
to the position right so the color will
be based on the position of the actual
pixel so what we'll write is pretty
simple we'll just write out Veck 3v
underscore position these kind of
variables that we transmitted between
shaders are called varying variables
that's what they used to be called so
I'm kind of used to that and that's why
I kind of give it a V underscore but it
doesn't matter what you pull it at all
we'll set V position here to be a
position all right and then over here we
need to have exactly the same code right
with exactly the same variable name
because that's how it matches it but
instead of out we write in okay and you
can transmit like entire like buffers as
well and you can make like structures
and do that instead but here we're just
doing individual theropods and then what
we'll do is we'll just output V position
instead of color and hopefully we get
something nice now that is pretty cool
you can see that we get like green up
there and red but we get this kind of
black thing here which there's black
kind of void here which I'm not really a
big fan of let's just discuss why we
actually get that
so zero zero is in the middle right
anything below zero any color values
below zero like negative 0.5 up just
zero right because colors are between
zero and one they kind of get clamped to
that range and because they get clamped
to that range if we have anything below
zero it's just black right because it
becomes
now clearly you can see that we kind of
moved to a green gradient here
the reason that's happening is because
as we get closer to one on the y-axis
what is the y-axis what is the Y
component of our color vector it's the
green channel because it goes RGB a so
XYZ is RGB with X as you can see being
red right what I want to do is actually
move this into a space that is a little
bit more friendly with kind of the space
that we're in right now right so
negative 1 to 1 is the current layout of
our vertices but the colors are 0 to 1
so what I'm gonna do is with this color
that we actually accept here I'm going
to multiply by 0.5 and add 0.5 so what
I've done here is since everything gets
multiplied by 0.5 it gets harmed and
then I'm adding 0.5 which moves it into
the into the 0 to 1 range so now it's
from 0 to positive 1 okay which means
that you know if you take an example
from this right
negative 0.5 becomes 0.25 right because
it gets harmed there negative 0.25 and
then add it to 0.25 so if this used to
be between negative 1 and 1 it used to
be a quarter of the way right now it's
between 0 and 1 and still quarter of the
way cos is 0.25 what this means is that
we shouldn't get any black at all on
this we're actually at the very very
bottom left edge so if we run this again
you can see we get something a little
bit nicer and we can actually see that
as we move over here we kind of lose all
of our red and we lose all of our green
and that's why it kind of just goes into
blue because blue is always going to be
0 which in this case is 0.5 because of
that transformation okay and if we were
to move this up to the top it would be
closer to actual like full green and
then if we move it like to the right
edge it would be it'll just become more
red we can actually try that and by
going over here and actually like adding
0.5 we'll have to add the 0.5 over here
to V position as well but now we should
actually get full red on the very right
side of the triangle and as
say we do here because we will because
we've also added green though it becomes
a bit lighter than it would otherwise be
but yeah you can see kind of how all
that works it's very easy to kind of
move data between the two shaders and
hopefully this gives you a bit of a bit
of an understanding as to what this GL
position and what this Apple color is
now the other big question that people
might have that are not used to graphics
API is is why is it not like why where
is this interpolation coming from right
you can see it's very smooth and that
just has to do with how the graphics API
works that's how rendering works what it
actually does is it interpolates as it
shades pixels between these values
unless you explicitly tell it not to
which you can do it actually will
smoothly linearly interpolate between
the two positions based on the value
that you actually give okay so because
we're sending a vector and the vector is
per vertex when it shades a pixel that
is like halfway between the two vertices
it will linearly interpolate that data
you set you've sent from the fetish
header to the fragment shader to be kind
of halfway through all right so anyway
that is how shaders work this is like a
very special episode I know I missed out
last week and I'm really sorry about
that the reason for that was just
because my audio recording kind of
failed halfway through and the
microphone cut out and I had to rerecord
the episode so I thought I'd give you
guys a bit of a special last week when I
recorded this it was not as
comprehensive at all it was just kind of
shaders let's just make the triangle
read done right I was like half the
length of this one so hopefully you guys
can forgive me and like just you know me
trying to put some extra work into this
episode I hope you guys enjoyed this let
me know what you think about everything
we've done today and hopefully you're
really excited but both shaders and by
the kind of physically based rendering
stuff that I've shown from the hazel
development branch I really do need your
help to make this series patron icon for
Sasha the Turner is the place to support
this if you like what I'm doing here on
YouTube trying to teach this kind of
game engine development and trying to
get you guys so indefinite expo
the powerful thing works and we're
building this kind of hazel engine
together your supports are really
important even if it's like small it
really is important for me to actually
be able to kind of do this and obviously
I want to spend as much time as possible
doing this stuff because I absolutely
love teaching I absolutely love
developing this kind of stuff and
hopefully you guys can kind of see that
by just who I am and the support of
obviously all of my patrons is what
makes this possible in the first place
so huge thank you to everyone next time
one thing that I want to do is I really
want to actually make more OpenGL
stories videos covering a lot of how
this stuff works
but I think next time like once we've
got this triangle now the most important
step is actually we've we've got a
vertex buffer we've got an index buffer
we've got a shader we need to move this
into kind of API specific classes right
it's all OpenGL specific code it's
currently sitting in our application
file which is cross-platform and cross
rendering API so what we need to do is
create actual classes out of all of this
deadlines in that OpenGL platform kind
of layer right so we talked about the
rendering API and how that's going to
kind of be abstracted per API now we
actually have to write that Sables cost
code to make that happen so I think
that's what we're going to move on to
next time oh what an episode I'll see
you next time goodbye
[Music]